Streams are another popular form of connector. They're primarily concerned with
data transfer, that is communication services. Common examples include pipes
TCP sockets and proprietary client-server type protocols. Some of the possible
variations available with stream connectors include delivery guarantees.
Whether the stream itself is bounded, that is, it only has a certain capacity or
whether it's unbounded and whether it's capable of buffering the information.
What its units of transmission are, that is, is it bytes or
is it something more higher order, more structured? Is it stateful or
stateless? Is it named or unnamed? Is it available only locally or
is it, is it more remote? Synchronous or asynchronous or timed? Law or
structured? And what's the cardinality? That is, is it definitely a one to
one type connection or might there be multiple receivers? Or might it
even be end to end where there are multiple riders and multiple receivers?